[Musik]
phoenix persönlich
in dieser plasma kugel wird deutlich wie
viel energie zum beispiel blitze in der
natur verursachen und wir brauchen alle
energie denn das will ich jetzt
besprechen mit dem physiker harald lesch
wir sind so ganz schön in einer knappen
situation was die energie anbetrifft die
komplette raus tja wenn ich das wüsste
dass wir also erst mal glaube ich muss
man sich darüber im klaren sein dass wir
schon auf einem energetisch sehr hohem
niveau leben
man kann das mal so vergleichen wenn wir
uns mal in einem fitnesscenter auf so
ein fahrrad setzen würden und würden
zehn stunden lang 100 watt treten etwa
eine kilowattstunde an energie umgesetzt
wir verbrauchen aber beide wenn man mal
die gesamtmenge die deutschland an
energie so braucht und dann durch die
zahl der tage im jahr und durch die
menschen sagen wir mal 80 millionen
teilen verbrauchen wir so mehr als 100
kilowattstunden das heißt während wir
hier stehen sind 99 andere sozusagen auf
den auf den ergometern unterwegs und
produzieren für uns setzen für uns
energie frei das heißt wir haben einfach
ein unglaublich hohem energiebedarf
warum weil bis jetzt energie so
bildsprache eine kilowattstunde was
bezahlen über denn ein paar cent oder 10
cent vielleicht 30 cent das heißt wir
haben uns auch noch gar nicht werden wir
sind es gar nicht gewöhnt dass wir für
energie energie ist immer da und das ist
gewissermaßen das märchen der moderne
das energie immer zur verfügung steht
wir können damit alles mögliche tun und
aktuell erleben wir jetzt zum ersten mal
wie sowohl ökonomische als
wirtschaftlicher als auch eben
tatsächliche randbedingungen dazu führen
dass weniger davon zur verfügung steht
denn meistens produzieren wir übersetzen
wir energie frei mit kohle öl und gas
oder mit also kernkraftwerken dass die
neuen die erneuerbaren energien eben
nichts verbrauchen sondern energie
umsetzen die von der sonne kommt oder
vom wind und so weiter das für uns eine
ganz neue situation und wir sind gerade
eine übergangsphase und wieso ist in
übergangsphasen
da gibt es ganz verschiedene wege und
aktuell sieht es so aus als wenn diese
fossilen ressourcen uns ganz gewaltige
probleme machen wir haben eine neue
bundesregierung diese neue
bundesregierung sagt wir brauchen diese
transformation hin zur alternativen
energien ja nicht nur deswegen weil öl
gas all das ja endlich ist und auf der
anderen seite eben auch für das
klimaschädliche da muss was passieren
und wir sind deswegen sagte ich engpass
wir sind in einer situation der ganz
viele länder ja erst einmal auf unsere
stufe konnten diene wollen ganz ganz
viel energie um ihre wirtschaft
anzutreiben den menschen ein leben zu
ermöglichen was besser ist als dass man
sie ewig leben das kann doch so nicht
funktionieren das wird außerordentlich
schwierig ist wird es wird für uns
bedeuten also man es ganz offen rechnet
richtig hart rechnet das wird für uns
bedeutet wir unseren energieverbrauch in
den industrialisierten ländern um 50
prozent reduzieren und damit allem dass
das eine denn man muss tatsächlich
energie und klima immer zusammen denken
wenn die anderen ihren energieverbrauch
hochheben und das werden sie vor allen
dingen zunächst einmal eben leider nicht
mit erneuerbaren tun dann wird der co2
ausstoß den wird dringend verhindern
müssen trotzdem noch weiter ansteigen
das heißt die industrienationen müssen
runter mit der energie die wenn die
anderen nationen hoch wollen oder die in
den industrienationen gelingt es die
erneuert die technologien für
erneuerbare energien so anzubieten dass
die länder auf den kontinenten wie
afrika oder in asien und südamerika
diese schwelle der fossilen ressourcen
völlig überspringen und direkt in die
erneuerbaren reingehen und das ist die
eigentliche frage schaffen es die
industrialisierten länder ihre
technologie in ihrem eigenen land so
weit zu entwickeln dass es so gut wenn
nicht verkaufen dann vielleicht sogar
verschenken können nun ist das ja auch
ein politisches problem ich muss ja dem
verbraucher auf der einen seite energie
möglich machen die er noch bezahlen kann
ja und auf der anderen seite muss ich
diese transformation antrag die
schwierig genug ist jetzt haben wir eine
diskussion auf europäischer ebene wie
ist das eigentlich mit gas wie ist das
eigentlich mit der atomenergie
machen wir in deutschland ein fehler
wenn wir sagen wir müssen die
atomkraftwerke
abschalten wir machen das auch bei der
kohle und fragen uns jetzt wie kriegen
wir das mit dem energie zu strom
überhaupt hin da scheint ja zunächst mal
scheint es ja kein problem zu sein wir
haben jetzt am anfang des jahres drei
kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet haben sie
was gemerkt ich habe nichts gemerkt
wahrscheinlich kann aber jetzt der strom
aus frankreich nicht und nicht
notwendigerweise er kam kam irgendwo her
aus dem europäischen netze die franzosen
an im gegenteil 15 ihrer kernreaktoren
kurz vor weihnachten abgeschaltet und
haben damit für ein riesenproblem am
europäischen strommarkt gesorgt weil die
firma zehn gigawatt leistung zusätzlich
brauchten die sie selber nicht mehr
bereit gestellt haben aber haben wir da
nicht in zweifel das problem dass wir
sagen wir wollen aus der atomenergie
raus wir wollen keine kohle mehr feuer
aber wir nehmen jetzt von den
kohlekraftwerken und polen etwas auf dem
europäischen energiemarkt
das ist das ist also der der strommarkt
ist eine außerordentlich komplizierte
angelegenheit wie wo ja sehr sehr viele
sehr viele quellen da sind zunächst
einmal haben wir in deutschland schon
einen anteil bei den erneuerbaren der
liegt bei 40 45 was den stromanteil
betrifft wenn wir die gesamtenergie
anschauen ist ist es sieht es ganz
anders aus das sind es weniger als 17
aber beim strom sind mir richtig gut das
heißt wir haben die hälfte des stromes
dem wir praktisch die hälfte des stroms
die wir momentan produzieren läuft aus
den erneuerbaren wir haben
gaskraftwerken wir machen wie vor
kohlekraftwerke und natürlich kann man
sich die frage stellen aber das ist
irgendwie vergossene milch wäre es 2011
nicht besser gewesen statt zu sagen wir
steigen aus der kernkraft aus wir
steigen aus der entsprechenden kohle aus
weil das für das klima natürlich einen
ganz anderen effekt gehabt hätte aber
die sache ist gelaufen die unternehmen
in deutschland sagen es wird keine
kernkraftwerken ergeben also müssen wir
uns der tatsache stellen wie kriegen wir
das stromnetz so stabil dass ist
weiterhin für uns alle eben mit zu
vernünftigen preisen energie darstellt
das ist energie präsentiert das ist
natürlich ein dass natürlich ein
ziemlicher aufwand steuerungs und
kontrollaufwand der ist enorm der wird
aber geleistet und gerade diese drei
kernkraft werde die abgeschaltet worden
sind am anfang des jahres es gab
überhaupt kein problem weil es ist
genügend strom nach deutschland
exportiert ja immer noch im laufe des
jahres jede menge elektrischen strom
weil wir eigentlich über sogar eine
überkapazität besitzen die zukunft wird
natürlich so sein wir brauchen eine
brückentechnologie für die sogenannte
grundlast wer der gasphase die hab ich
und mein gas co2 ausstoß der ist halb so
hoch ist halb so hoch das
allerwichtigste allerdings ist das eben
die gaskraftwerke eine anschluss fähige
technologie darstellen wenn wir mehr
erneuerbaren strom haben können wir aus
dem erneuerbaren strom wasserstoff
machen und mit dem können wir die
gaskraftwerke übertreiben kernkraft
hingegen ist in dieser hinsicht eines
sackgassen technologie weil sie für den
allgemeinen nachhaltigkeits begriff
natürlich eine katastrophe darstellt
weil sie unglaubliche ewigkeitskosten
erzeugt wir sehen in deutschland je
hatte die hertha energieunternehmen aus
der endlagerung problematik mit 24
milliarden rausgekauft die haben dafür
bezahlt was wird auf die zukünftigen
generationen in deutschland zu kommen
möglicherweise etwas von zwischen 100
und 170 milliarden die bundesanstalt für
die sicherung der endlagerung ist der
recht vage aber es wird um einen
dreistelligen milliardenbetrag gehen
wenn zum endlager geht und davon spricht
man nicht wenn ich daran denke dass die
europäische kommission einen vorschlag
macht die kernkraft zu einer
nachhaltigen energiequellen zu erziehen
da muss ich natürlich sagen dann hat
hier einen sehr sagen wir mal sehr
sportlichen nachhaltigkeit aber das
heißt ja auch das ist ja nicht nur ein
energieproblem sollen auch ein
politisches und bildung als
strategisches problem weil sie gerade
auch gas angesprochen haben im
zusammenhang mit der gas partner noch
zwei zum beispiel eine wirklich massive
politische probleme weil wir nicht hier
hingehen können machen loch in die erde
und haben plötzlich gas ja wir müssen
das hier irgendwo hin bekommen und dann
geht es direkt um schwierige
strategische politische probleme das was
energie anbetrifft ist auch immer ein
strategisches problem also das war das
schon immer energie ist immer ein
strategisches problem viele kriege sind
geführt worden wegen der ölvorkommen im
nahen und mittleren osten und man muss
sich natürlich weil es ist ganz klar
energie ist in der physik heiße so schön
energie ist eine größe die die fähigkeit
arbeit zu leisten bestimmt also wenn ich
was machen will brauche ich gegen eine
energiequelle und ich will jetzt hier
keine geschichte der energieverteilung
sehen aber wir wissen natürlich öl war
der dominante stoff des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts er hat die moderne
angetrieben dann haben wir festgestellt
mit öl kohle und gas kommen wir nicht
weiter wir brauchen was anderes und gott
sei dank hat man ja mit den erneuerbaren
ist mit technologien zu tun die von der
von der grundsätzlichen dimension her so
einfach sind dass wir sie überall auf
dem globus hinstellen können windräder
ich sage immer wind gab es schon vor den
windrädern man hätte sie in den 50er
jahren in deutschland zum beispiel auch
stadt für die kernkraft für die
windkraft entscheiden aber würde sich
mal vor was wir für eine entscheidung
war wenn sie windkraft ansprechen da
haben wir die forderung des neuen
wirtschafts und klimapolitik
und minister saerbeck der sagt wir
müssen zum beispiel mit bayern mal reden
die abstände der windkraftanlagen ja es
ist weiter ein innenpolitisch massives
problem
die zukunft eben mal hier über höher
denn wir sind ja hier im institut für
plasmaphysik das heißt es geht hier um
etwas was vielleicht die energie der
zukunft zukunft sagen könnte nämlich die
kernfusion was können wir hier an diesem
netten gerät so etwas was wir hier sehen
ist im prinzip ein davonlaufen des
plasma und mit plasma ist zunächst
einmal ein ionisiertes gas also wir
stehen jetzt hier atmen die atemluft 1
da gibt es ein paar ganz wenige geladene
teilchen aber das ist ansonsten
neutrales gas wenn wir das jetzt
aufteilen in elektronen und ionen also
die elektro negativ geladene ionen sie
positiv geladen dann kann man damit so
ein ding erzeugen wie ein elektrischer
strom der kann fließen und der
elektrische strom erzeugt ein magnetfeld
und dass das magnetfeld verbietet den
teilchen sozusagen ganz sich frei zu
bewegen und deswegen hat man immer
wieder solche zylinderförmigen
strukturen das ist als der fließenden
strom bewegen sich ladungen und darum
drum oben liegt das magnetfeld und das
ist die große chance ein prozess der
eigentlich nur für sterne bestimmt ist
nämlich der fusionsprozess die
verschmelzung von kleinen atomkern so
größer also von wasserstoff zu helium in
einer in einer magnetischen einschluss
kammer praktisch im labor nachzubauen
das ist der große traum der kernfusion
und alles was wir hier so sehen an
anlageteilen hat immer was damit zu tun
dass man in einem solchen ring versucht
ein gas plasma das 100 millionen grad
heißes zusammenzuhalten und dabei die
kerne dazu zu bringen miteinander zu
verschmelzen schlussendlich mehr energie
soll frei werden als sich rein stecken
um diese anlage zubereiteter sollen
ungefähr mal 10 mal mehr energie sein
als die die ich rein stellen das ist
aber leider ziemlich kompliziertes und
das für die ja nur wissenschaftler
andererseits auch faszinierend weil das
was hier quasi auf der erde
möglicherweise funktionieren könnte
irgendwann mal das funktioniert die
ganze zeit auf der samen in den sternen
ist es ganz einfach die haben einfach so
viel masse und so viel druck darauf dass
die die atomkerne im inneren tatsächlich
dazu zwingen miteinander zu
funktionieren allerdings mit einer
relativ geringen effizienz in der sonne
wird nur ein zusammenstoß von einer
trillion also von 10 hoch 18
zusammenstößen ist tatsächlich
erfolgreich aber die leuchtkraft der
sonne entsteht dadurch dass so viele
teilchen da sind das dann immer noch
genügend energie dabei frei wird und
diese energie drängt nach außen drückt
praktisch den stern auseinander der
stern hat seine schwerkraft und das
können wir auf der erde alles nicht
erzeugen wir brauchen hier die kraft der
magnetfelder die das plasma zusammenhält
und das ist aber zugleich das problem
wenn man nehme ich das mal so anschaut
wenn ich nehmen wir an wir hätten hier
also sowas wie ein blitz wenn wir blitz
haben ganz in der nähe von der metall
warnt dann schlägt der blitz natürlich
auf diese metallband durch das heißt wir
müssen die wand weg kriegen das heißt
sie müssen die anlagen groß bauen und
deswegen ist der große forschungsreaktor
iter der jetzt in südfrankreich gebaut
wird das ist der erste reaktor von dem
wir ausgehen dass er tatsächlich mehr
energie freisetzen wird als wir
einstecken müssen da was ist ein
forschungsreaktor denn es gibt immer
noch
forschungsfragen die nicht geklärt sind
wir können noch keine anlage bauen die
wir sozusagen in die technologische
phase gebracht haben wo wir einfach
sagen können das funktioniert ganz
automatisch so wie wir beide zum
beispiel unsere autos benutzen die autos
sind längst in einer technologischen
ingenieur phase und das können wir bei
der kernfusion leider noch nicht aber in
20 bis 25 jahren würdest du anders sein
wir müssen nochmal über kernfusion
sprechen weil das die energie der
zukunft sein könnte und jan ist eine der
zentralen energiequellen der zukunft und
dazu gehen wir hier nochmal ein stück
weg
tokamak ja heißt sozusagen der nukleus
das allererste
experiment von 1973 was war denn
eigentlich die idee wir sind ja bei der
kernfusion also eigentlich eine art von
abbild dessen was in der natur
stattfinden ja was die natur eben kann
in den sternen ist aufgrund der eigenen
gravitation den druck auf die materie so
zu erhöhen dass die atomkerne
tatsächlich dort miteinander
verschmelzen wir können haben diese
schwere nicht wir haben diese masse
nicht jede man dazu verbraucht denn die
sonne zb ist 333 1000 mal schwerer als
die sonne als die erde also es wird mir
gar nicht hinkriegen also was wir
brauchen ist eine kraft die dieses
geladene die diese geladenen teilchen
zusammenhält und da war die relativ
frühen 50er jahren schon vor allen
dingen der sowjetunion entwickelt die
totale kammer der zuckermarkt ist ein
ausdruck für
totale eine totale kann man sieht aus
wie ein donut und was man so will und
darin ist das plasma
eingesperrt und das wäre halt schön wenn
das plasma so lange da drin bliebe man
sieht es hier wenn es so lange in der
kammer bliebe das sich dann atomkerne
leichter atomkerne miteinander
verschmelzen und jetzt scheinen wir
tatsächlich an dem punkt angekommen zu
sein mit dem neuen großen reaktor etat
der wird der erste reaktor sein wo all
diese probleme zumindest gelöst sein
können wo wir sie lösen können und damit
haben wir zum ersten mal einen richtigen
forschungsreaktor wo mehr energie
rauskommen wird als wir einstecken
können früher mal uns anschauen bilder
und auch ein modell von etr das heißt
aber wir sind da wieder in einer
größenordnung eines großen sehr großen
sehr sehr sehr großen anlage
frankreich steht der
man sagt ja immer sie haben es gerade
schon erwähnt das geht dann in den
nächsten jahren los aber sind enorm
verzögerungen dabei eher interessant ist
das ist ja eine sehr internationale
gemeinschaft jetzt die diesen die dieser
forschung nachgeht interessanterweise
auch china russland usa europa zusammen
was ja eigentlich ein gutes zeichen ein
unbedingt ich meine das ist eigentlich
ein so gutes zeichen dass man viel viel
häufiger darüber reden müsste ist eine
dieser großen wissenschaftlichen
projekte wo die ganze menschheit
zusammenarbeitet und anstatt das ständig
zu feiern und eigentlich jeden abend bei
jeder nachricht noch einmal zu sagen
mensch die arbeiten da zusammen sprechen
wir viel viel häufiger über die
konflikte denn genau solche projekte
sind ja auch anlass dazu dass menschen
das länder das auch auf politische
systeme sich wieder neu kennenlernen und
auf diese art und weise merken menschen
immer was zusammen machen das ist ja
viel viel vernünftiger als wenn wir
sozusagen auf konflikt auf konflikt
aussehen aber es könnte ja zwei gründe
geben einmal ist es unglaublich teuer
das heißt das kann eine nation gar nicht
alleine machen und zum zweiten der druck
ist enorm groß wir haben darüber
gesprochen
die energie muss zur verfügung stehen
wir brauchen immer mehr energie auf der
erde und irgendwann muss das
funktionieren sonst haben wir ein
problem wir müssen ja sehen die
transformation von dem wir vorher
gesprochen haben ist ja vor allen dingen
die transformation hin alle möglichen
energieformen ihn eine zu über übergehen
zu lassen dem in elektrische energie
also wir wollen keine fossilen
ressourcen mehr wir wollen möglichst
auch keine eingriffe in die landschaften
haben wir wollen wenn es nur irgendwie
geht alles in form von elektrischer
energie haben toll wäre ein großer
anlagen in der wüste und so weiter
einfach um die um die sonne zu lösen um
die sonnenenergie zu benutzen und so
weiter aber am ende geht es darum
tatsächlich alle energiebereiche
komplett zu elektrifizieren unsere
mobilität unserer kommunikation ist es
ja heute schon aber auch
industrieprozesse und so weiter alle
ganz anders zu betreiben als wir das
heute tun und das muss langfristig auf
eine solche anlage oder solche anlagen
muss es zurückgehen wird tatsächlich
auch bei den erneuerbaren natürlich in
begrenzungen haben und das fatale ist
nun für die kernfusion dass sie wenn sie
da sein wird wird es zu spät sein
stichwort klimawandel da wird sie
bestimmt erst einen anteil liefern
können wenn wir wenn wir jetzt die
richtigen wenn wir jetzt die richtige
richtungsentscheidung treffen
das sticht in richtung neben klimaschutz
dann könnte bis ende des jahrhunderts
die kernfusion sozusagen dabei sein und
könnte das helfen also da kommt es jetzt
wirklich drauf an dass eine zu tun ohne
das andere zu lassen nun ist ja immer
die frage nebenwirkungen einer neuen
technologie ist es bei der kernfusion so
dass wir eine nebenwirkung haben die
überschaubar ist und die wir auch
beherrschen oder ist es ähnlich wie bei
der atomkraft wo wir sagen eigentlich
funktioniert das prima aber wir haben
das schlicht das problem was machen wir
mit dem atom also hier die bei der
kernfusion feld abfall in kaum also im
vergleich zu den eskalation reaktoren
also in kernkraftwerken die wir heute
benutzen fällt hier kaum radioaktives
material an also das kann man fast in
anführungsstrichen vernachlässigen
sollte es natürlich nicht tun aber das
ist nicht das größte problem zurzeit ist
das größte problem immer noch dass
dieser im prinzip physikalisch mögliche
prozess technologisch noch nicht so
beherrscht wird wie wir es bräuchten um
es in technologische anlagen einzusetzen
das sind die schritte das heißt hier
haben wir auch mit einer transformation
zu tun nämlich aus der forschung in die
technische welt hinein zu kommen das
sind die nächsten dekaden die der
fusionsforschung bevorstehen und das
kann gelingen wir wissen es physikalisch
möglich es kann gelingen und damit wäre
natürlich sozusagen die perspektive für
die club für eine globale energiepolitik
würde tatsächlich auf die fusion zu
laufen
naturwissenschaften funktioniert nach
dem try and error prinzip also nach dem
prinzip ich probiere etwas aus und
entweder funktionäre so funktioniert
nicht und ich lerne daraus ich
experimentiere
try and error hört sich so an so ich
probier mal irgendwas aus sondern es
gibt natürlich theorien oder es gibt
hypothesen und diese hypothesen machen
nur vorhersagen und wenn diese
vorhersage durch ein experiment
bestätigt wird dann folge ich diese
hypothese das heißt es geht immer darum
prognosen zu bestätigen um rauszufinden
ist da was dran oder ist da nichts dran
das interessante ist dass prognosen
teilweise sich eben immer noch
verstärken oder das theorien sich
dadurch verstärken sie werden einmal
bestätigt noch einmal bestätigt und dann
werden sie immer fester und fester zum
bestandteil von physik aber das
entscheidende ist das eben bei dieser
empirischen forschung ist nicht darum
geht darstellt jemand eine these auf
jemand kommt mit einer anti these und
dann gibt es vielleicht eine synthese so
aller regel sondern es geht auch nicht
um meinungen oder interpretationen
sondern es geht darum wir haben eine
eine vorstellung davon lieber eine
messung machen können eine messung eine
beobachtung und wenn diese messungen
beobachtung die vorstellung bestätigt
dann gehen wir weiter so sondern ganz
andere art von von fortführung von
erkenntnis da ist eine these antithese
synthese
das ist quasi ein diskurs ein im zweifel
auch diskurs in der gesellschaft und die
versteht oft nicht wie funktioniert denn
eigentlich wissenschaft und deswegen
müssen wir da noch mal darüber sprechen
ja
in ihrem buch denkt mit haben sie mal
dargestellt wie wissenschaft eigentlich
arbeitet wie die funktioniert das ist
den meisten leuten nicht klar und
deswegen gibt es auch jetzt gerade in
der aktuellen situation viele
missverständnisse
ich sage jetzt bewusst missverständnisse
bei viele kennen die arbeitsweise nicht
manche ignorieren sie manchmal wird es
auch gerne ideologisch benutzt so im
sinne von jeder wissenschaftler sagt was
anderes kein wunder ihr habt keine
ahnung
sie haben beschrieben wie wissenschaft
funktioniert was ist der kern ist dass
das irren und schauen wie ist es
wirklich also der kern ist eigentlich
der zweifel und zwar nicht der
seelenzustand das verzweifelt sein
sondern ich glaub das noch nicht ich
glaube da ist noch mehr dahinter das
hinterfragen spielt eine wichtige rolle
aber dann vor allen dingen nicht nur zu
spekulieren sondern zugleich die
möglichkeit anzugeben wie kann ich das
testen kann ich es irgendwie
herausfinden mit hilfe einer beobachtung
und einer messung also quantitativ ich
muss immer was berechnen können ich muss
was messen können was zählen können das
ist in der bionischen forschung des
landes
das heißt nicht die behauptung steht da
im mittelpunkt sondern eine begründete
behauptung die dann noch getestet wird
der test ist sozusagen die guillotine
die jede theorie muss ihren kopf in
diese gut ihnen legen und wenn die
bestätigung nicht stattfindet dann ist
die theorie tot das ist der ganz harte
verlauf in wirklichkeit ist es natürlich
so dass hypothesen modifiziert werden zu
nehmen wir zum beispiel mal die these
viren sind molekulare maschine
molekulare maschinen die sich ständig
verändern und die eben auch dann ständig
neue eigenschaften haben ist in der
biologie in der medizin längst der stand
der dinge aber es gibt menschen in der
öffentlichkeit die bestreiten dass die
bestreiten sogar die existenz von mir
und es sind alles nur erfindungen aber
wir haben natürlich eine ganze menge an
hinweisen aus den beobachtungen
experimenten in den lebenswissenschaften
die exakt das bestätigen was die theorie
von den viren als molekulare maschinen
eben vorhergesagt haben das heißt ich
kann natürlich eine behauptung haben es
gibt diesen wunderbaren satz ich weiß
gar nicht von wem jeder hat das recht
auf eine eigene meinung aber nicht auf
eigene fakten und wenn wir von den
tatsachen sprechen da ist eben eine
meinung dazu zu haben schlecht ich kann
mich darüber ärgern dass die sonne im
osten aufgeht und im westen unter nicht
umgekehrt jetzt kann man ja verstehen
dass vereinigung in der bevölkerung
viele den die aber die struktur der
wissenschaft nicht verstehen das wären
diejenigen denen man eigentlich wie sie
es in dem buch versucht haben erklären
sollte wie wissenschaft funktioniert es
gibt aber zunehmend menschen die das
einfach ignorieren was machen wir denn
da
man kann eigentlich nichts anderes tun
als immer wieder anzulaufen und auf neue
art und weise versuchen über
wissenschaft was zu erzählen also ich
glaube das ist ja das war ganz wichtig
dass wissenschaft nicht daherkommt
praxis so von oben herab sondern
versucht tatsächlich türen und fenster
aufzumachen um den menschen vor allem
den klar zu machen die welt in der du
lebst
die ganzen technologien um dich herum
das ist bereits dass ergebnisse
wissenschaftlicher forschung du würdest
gar nicht kommunizieren können sie gar
nicht bewegen können technisch weder mit
dem auto noch in zugenommen flugzeug
wenn wir diese ganze wissenschaft nicht
betrieben hätten und sie dir das doch
machen dass technik eine fortführung von
wissenschaftlicher forschung ist und ich
glaube das könnte vielleicht ein weg
sein um leute noch mal klar zu machen ja
ich kann das gar nicht ignorieren
schlimmer ist es natürlich wenn es
ideologisch und wann ist es fast
unmöglich da rein zu bleiben die das
ignorieren oder eben zweifelsfall sich
auch so ein bisschen von der kakophonie
beeinflussen lassen die ja inzwischen
vor allen dingen auch das hier sozialen
medien haben das heißt da ist ein
wissenschaftler der sagt etwas im
gegensatz zu der großen mehrzahl anderer
wissenschaftler ich finde diese these
aber so interessant dass ich die nehmen
und sagen die anderen mehr unrecht
merkwürdig weil wir beide würden kaum
den blinddarm operieren lassen und dem
operateur dem chirurgen sagen wollen
wieder das machen so genau auch nicht
dem bäcker wie er den wagen aber
wie kommt es dazu dass wir diese
kakofonie nicht unterbrechen können
also das scheint mir so zu sein dass es
eben ein medium gibt das sehr sehr viele
von diesen nachrichten die mir gut
gefallen mir sehr nahe bringen kann also
das heißt da werden auf einmal thesen
werden behauptungen aufgestellt die im
prinzip so ein bisschen genauso sind wie
manche dieser ignorierenden das
tatsächlich gedacht haben und dann
fühlen sie sich bestätigt heutzutage
haben wir ja im internet eine dauer
stammtisch situation die man früher
wirklich nur in der kneipe hatte da
haben sich leute zusammen gesetzt und
haben irgendwelche teilweise abstrusen
dinge
abgesondert aber das ist dann in der
runde geblieben und dann sind sie wieder
auseinander gegangen da war es gut heute
haben wir mit dem internet praktisch ein
riesen kneipe wo alle möglichen dinge
gehört und gelesen werden können und wo
sich leute bestätigt fühlen können ich
fand den satz interessant die mir ein
spanischer kollege gesagt hat in einer
bar in madrid wirst du kein querdenker
querdenker wirst du wenn du alleine vor
deiner vor deinem bildschirm sitzt und
sich praktisch selbst radikalisiert
indem du praktisch nur noch merkwürdige
merkwürdige informationsquellen last
aber in der bahn madrid da wird man die
sagen was du da jetzt heißt es doch
völliger plätze aber wir haben ja ein
ganz besonderes problem in dieser
pandemie zwischen politik und
wissenschaft
viele wissenschaftler
wissen nicht wie sie kommunizieren mit
der gesellschaften aber auch nicht mit
der politik und machen da auch viele
fehler das muss ich persönlich ja auch
enorm ärgern weil eine voraussage im
sinne von wir haben einen impfstoff und
wenn ihr zwei mal geimpft sagt dann sagt
ihr quasi raus dann ist alles wieder gut
die haben sich nicht bestätigt warum hat
man einen solchen fehler gemacht na ja
wir sind natürlich in der situation die
ja oft die niemand vorbereitet was wäre
hoffentlich das wäre zu wünschen dass
als konsequenz aus dieser pandemie
heraus auch darüber nachgedacht wird wie
steht in zukunft wissenschaft politik
und gesellschaft gegenüber und wie
stehen gesellschaft der politik der
wissenschaft gegenüber eines kann man
sagen politik ist wissenschaftlicher
geworden also die politik braucht
wissenschaftliche beratung
politikberatung ständig weil die
vorgänge werden nicht nur komplizierter
sie werden komplexer und da die
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentarier
noch die regierenden diese art von
know-how gar nicht bereitstellen können
brauchen sie auf jeden fall politische
wissenschaftliche politikberatung
andererseits wird aber damit auch die
wissenschaft politischer weil sie kommt
näher an die politik heran sie wird auf
einmal befragt werden was haltet ihr
davon sagt doch mal also weiter das
heißt es kommt wirklich darauf an sich
vor allen dingen die zeit zu nehmen
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse auch mal
wirklich zu verstehen und nicht nur so
ein bisschen ist auch eine frage der
zeit kultur in den wissenschaften laufen
die dinge langsam ab in der politik wird
häufig sehr sehr schnell gefragt und auf
eine antwort die gegeben worden ist wird
so schnell reagiert dass man sagen muss
wäre vielleicht besser gewesen der oder
diejenige hätte noch eine nacht darüber
geschlafen
das heißt wir laufen auf etwas zu das
könnte eine große große konsequenz aus
corona sein dass politik wissenschaft
und gesellschaft sich ganz anders
gegenseitig wahrnehmen sich gegenseitig
die türen und fenster öffnen und damit
es möglich machen dass gesellschaft
sieht erstens mal wir bezahlen dass wir
bezahlen die wissenschaft dann haben wir
ein anrecht darauf zu erfahren was die
machen die wissenschaft erfährt aha das
sind die fragen die an uns gestellt
werden wir definieren wir nun unsere
forschungs projekte nicht mehr nur
alleine aus uns heraus sondern wir
reagieren darauf was öffentlichkeit was
politik für fragen hat und beschäftigen
uns mit nicht nur mit wissenschaftlich
interessanten sondern auch eine
gesellschaftliche politisch relevanten
themen und wenn das gelingt ich glaube
dann würde auch die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung größer werden dann würde man
auf die frage wo ist denn die
universität sagen können warten sie ich
für sehen ich zeige ihnen wo unsere
universität ist das wäre der positive
ausgang wir haben aber den vorwurf der
manifest ist in vielen bereichen der
öffentlichkeit dass sich die
wissenschaftler ja im grunde instrument
ihre instrumentalisieren lassen von der
politik
also das kann ich überhaupt nicht sehen
dafür gibt es einfach viel zu viele
verschiedene beratungsinstitutionen die
politik beraten die politik informieren
es ist meistens im gegen so dass es
gerade typisches beispiel ist jetzt die
entscheidung der eu-kommission für die
taxonomie da gibt es ein beratungs starb
und offenbar ist fast nichts was dieser
beratung starb der eu kommission
vorgeschlagen hat in dem vorschlag der
im silvester veröffentlicht worden ist
tatsächlich drin die leute sind außer
sich sie toben förmlich wie so sätze wie
da sind so werden vergleiche angestellt
wenn man wie gas und kernkraft
nachhaltig macht also könnte man auch
sagen vom fritz ist der neue salat es
völliger blödsinn oder die die
rüstungsindustrie wird sagen wir sind
auch nachhaltig denn sicherheit ist die
bedingung für nachhaltigkeit überhaupt
es gibt tatsächlich auch schon anträge
also was man eher was man er sieht es
das wissenschaftliche
beratungsinstitutionen gegründet werden
und das sei richtig viel arbeit gemacht
und einen tollen gutachten gemacht wenn
ich an den wissenschaftlichen beirat für
globale umweltveränderungen zum beispiel
denke ein großartiger oder den
sachverständigenrat für umweltfragen usw
und es wird aber von der politik nicht
wahrgenommen warum wird es nicht
wahrgenommen weil offenbar die zeit auch
in dem politischen
vorgängen gar nicht mehr da ist um sich
einer wissenschaftlichen erklärung unter
einem wissenschaftlichen empfehlungen
mal so zuzuwenden dass man wirklich mal
versteht aha das ist das was sie meinen
das müssten wir tun und ich würde sagen
eine ganz wichtige ein ganz wichtiges
problem unserer zeit ist das zu wenig
zeit da ist wenn wir schon unsere welt
immer komplexer machen dann können wir
nicht so tun als könnten wir sie
behandeln wie eine spielzeugeisenbahn
das ist eben nicht so und da ist
sozusagen die sowieso ehrliches namen
der kollateralschaden in der
gesellschaft ist dann unverständnis bis
hin zu heftiger aggression ablehnung und
sogar hass was sind die beiden
konsequenzen wenn wir aus der pandemie
in die emi kommen und damit eine art von
normalzustand wieder erleben können was
sind die konsequenzen aus ihrer sicht
als wissenschaftler für die wissenschaft
für den diskurs mit der wissenschaft
auch für das ansehen der wissenschaft in
der gesellschaft also ich glaube gerade
was diese ganz besonders abstrakten
themen betrifft und eben auch wenn wir
so viren als molekulare maschinen
darstellen wenn es um rna zum beispiel
geht alles begriffe die wir in den
letzten zwei jahren ja gelernt haben
dann merken wir dass wir den enormen
element arisierung bedarf haben das
heißt also der weg in das
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse so für die
öffentlichkeit aufbereitet werden müssen
dass sie verständlich werden dass sie
wirklich verstanden werden und damit
auch klar wird was ist die
leistungsfähigkeit von empirischer
forschung also von den
naturwissenschaften medizin den
technologie wissenschaften aber auch was
sind ihre grenzen und vor allen dingen
mit welchen was sind die visionen die
wir alle davon haben wie soll unser land
unsere gesellschaft unser kontinent
aussehen der ja von wissenschaft und
technologie geprägt ist wie soll er
aussehen damit eben diese neuen diese
neuentwicklungen unser leben nicht
schlechter machen sondern besser das
bedeutet im grunde muss ich muss ich
wirklich sagen wir müssen uns viel mehr
zeit nehmen dafür dass wirklich zu
verstehen was wir da treiben und uns
nicht von diesen ökonomischen imperativ
immer weiter antreiben zu lassen
manchmal ist es besser einfach mal
innezuhalten und zu überlegen sind wir
da wo wir hinwollen er ist die
geisteswissenschaftliche perspektive
nämlich ganz wichtig dass zurück blicken
und zu sagen haben wir das erreicht was
wir erreichen wollten und korrektur
fähigkeit ich glaube das ist das
allerwichtigste fehler nicht als einen
fehler zu sehen und dann treten die
leute zurück oder verschwinden sondern
haye den fehler haben wir gemacht den
machen wir nicht noch mal das ist glaube
ich eine der wichtigsten sachen
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
war mein vergleich vielen dank
[Musik]